yo what up this is Jason Lee from
Hollywood unlocked you can catch me on
the bootleg Kev podcast
show special guest in here
the conglomerate known as Jason Lee you
know so funny when I first moved to LA
and I was a consultant I was Consulting
people on [__] my company was called the
conglomerate group oh really I swear to
God well then check you out man you're
building yourself a media Empire
um congratulations on the new show thank
you uh I think it's dope too because I
saw like kind of like the well first of
all I I always preferred Hollywood
unlocked over shade room and baller
alert because I always thought you guys
they're great I'm letting you know if I
if you were to go to my saved posts yeah
over the last like six years 90 of all
of my news
Hollywood online is Hollywood unlocked
bro why why Hollywood unlocked I just
feel like you guys were like like I feel
like you guys are more like
uh active I guess if that makes sense I
feel like baller alert sometimes like I
might get like five or six posts a day
some days we're like if I'm like really
trying to see what the [__] like going
on like in real time like I'll go to you
or you know even like my mixtapes like
post [__] like I like but they're pretty
active too they're like super active but
I do feel like you know you've kind of
all uh for me been like a great source
of like doing show prep you know just as
a radio personality and now you're
[__] killing it I've you know I loved
what you were doing with damage
um during the pandemic
um and to see you kind of
turn into
Jason Lee being kind of like as big or
bigger than your company and the Jason
Lee show man just congrats thank you
thank you yeah I first want to shout out
Robin and and um and Angie Angie two
amazing women who you know inspire me in
different ways Angie at the showroom was
somebody who was shade rooms like the
like the the Michael Jordan of this
right there well we're all different you
know and that's the thing you know when
I first came in the game everybody was
saying oh don't do Hollywood unlocked
because the shade room and ball alert's
been here before everybody and shape
room has as many followers and there's
no room in the space and I always
believed in myself I was always like
[__] what y'all talking about I'm gonna
do what I want to do I mean I'm a person
who survived the hood I came out of
nothing I [__] been shot I've seen
all types of [__] happen like there's no
way you survive all that and think that
you can't be anything you want to be
Angie at the showroom was the first to
really like guide me on how to build
she's super cool too she's a sweetheart
yeah how to build audience how to really
connect with them and how to focus on
your content and then Robin when I lost
my Instagram was the person who guided
me through the lawsuit and checked on me
every day and even still today with the
new show checks on me and we have a
great relationship and they have a dough
baller alert radio is dope like they're
both dope all alerts in the films we're
all just very different I think the one
thing that makes us unique where I think
think you see me more is Jason Lee is
also a brand in the face of Hollywood
online so you see me a lot more you hear
my shows and my interviews and so you
see me more I don't know that's what
whoever's posting for y'all is just on
top of it bro they're on it they're
killing it like I'm like it's crazy
because like I used to be like let me
check tfz or something like no let me
see Hollywood a lot posted I know yo I
know when you posted that the queen died
me and my co-host James Jefferson we
were like praying we were like and and
this is like a bad thing okay we weren't
we weren't praying that she was no y'all
wanted her to be dead no we didn't want
her to be dead you wanted the story but
I was like very like I was like oh this
is huge yeah this would be huge if Jason
Nails it hot like when something like
that happens obviously it didn't end she
ended up passing away after but
allegedly oh medicine social media you
know they killed me oh I was wrong and
then you know you didn't really see her
and then they came back and said oh
Jason was right the whole time you know
I you know I have to say in the business
that I'm in you have to trust your
sources
I've learned a lot since that experience
though like you try to still trust the
source because the source if I ever said
the source which I won't I mean is
somebody that all of us would just gag
if you just heard the person who told me
but then shout out to Prince Harry I'm
kidding okay I wasn't I wish
um but no I mean like but then at this
on the other hand it was a huge Gamble
and you know we rode the dice and you
know sometimes you hit and sometimes you
don't and it was just one of those
things where I loved that I went through
that because it just showed everybody
that I was human we made a mistake you
know we came back and owned it and we
corrected and we kept it pushing and we
we're still getting deals we're still
growing you know so for people who don't
know you're are you from Stockton
Stockton yeah so the 209 is a very
serious place people don't understand it
like that's why they were talking about
how ruthless the industry is Stockton's
crazy yeah it's a lot my manager Brian
Sampson is from Stockton right I mean
unfortunately for both of us yeah and uh
one day he convinced me to not take us a
flight home from San Francisco because I
was going to fly from Sanford just go
back to Burbank and he was driving and
he was like bro I don't want to drive
alone just just drive with me you know
you'll get you'll get there in the
morning so I'm like fine I'll go with
you to Stockton no no no we're supposed
to drive from the bay back to LA okay so
I pass out in the front seat and I wake
up in the middle of the [__]
The Trenches of Stockton while he's
giving me an unvolunteered like Hood
Vlog tour at like one in the morning
and it yeah it's a rough place man
Stockton serious tell me a little bit
about just like a childhood growing up
man yeah Brian's a HomeTown hero too
because even earlier in my you know when
I was before the industry I always heard
of he would always he did great making
it to La working in the music business
and then he would always go home and DJ
fly and he would give people hope that
they could make it in the business but
um and I don't have a relationship with
them I just know of them of course lucky
for you by the way Stockton is great I
mean you know even though it's a
difficult City I really feel like it's
it has its challenges like most inner
city communities around the world around
the country
um I grew up with a white mom and a
black father who was always married to
his wife she just passed away a couple
weeks ago and you know I didn't have a
relationship with them the way that I
had with my mom but um you know I was a
product of my community I I tried to
sell drugs wasn't good at that got shot
watched my brother get murdered had lots
of friends die I was talking to my
friend the other day that when I think
about how many people died in the year
of just 1997 alone my brother tons of
friends I was almost at a funeral every
other week for like three or four months
and uh and I'm and I really look at
Stockton as
um the place where I first got my um
interest in the business I met Queen
Latifah that that light that idea that I
could be more than my my community was
there but now I'm back building my
foundation and working with my mayor my
city council to launch an initiative
called the I'm ready initiative where
we're going to Target black and brown
kids to bring in all the people I built
their relationship with to create
programming and you know Zoom meetings
and stuff with these kids to give them
hope but then embedded in that is a lot
of Behavioral change and program and
systemic changes that they have to make
in order to be eligible so I'm excited I
don't see I know the narrative about
Stockton and it's true it is dangerous
um but there's also so much hope there
and I always look at an opportunity
where okay yeah it may be [__] up but
if the right people care enough then
they'll do what it takes to make it
better yeah it seems like a lot of the
up-and-coming artists like have died
recently
um it's rough man there's like super
dope thriving Hip-Hops to me Stockton is
like the most exciting scene in hip-hop
in like in California oh really it's
bubbling yeah I'm not as tapped in on
the music it's it's lit yeah shout out
to everybody doing their thing out there
we had uh the Haiti baby do you know who
of course of course the freestyle on our
show that went viral no no because of
you I saw him and then he came on my
show and I think he came on my show at a
time where he wasn't really ready to do
the media because he was just new yeah
but he's super talented and and now that
I've seen him grow and come to LA and
I've had lunch with him and um and met
him again very articulate super solid
dude man very good person and he had
these very talented and I know a lot of
people who man are watching him yeah
Jeezy just uh he just signed a CTE with
cheesy oh nice so congrats to him
um so how do you get from being a kid
from Stockton who's been through so much
[__] uh to LA
well I had a job I mean before
entertainment I worked for a labor union
called SEIU I was the staff director for
Kaiser Permanente so Kaiser hospitals
all throughout California I was one of
the three directors who who led a team
of organizers who organized all the
Hospitals and Clinics so um that came by
way of me losing my job but being you
know very vocal with the city about what
I felt was right or wrong about the
firing they saw me advocating for myself
they offered me a job I was a Kaiser
patient at the time I felt like yo now
I'm going to be a Kaiser patient with
the privilege of advocating for other
patients at the level of organizing the
leaders so I did that work for 11 years
and when we merged with at the time it
was local 250 emerged with local 399 it
became
sciuhw I was the first to have to come
down and help lead the Statewide program
to really move people into what the
union was going to be about and uh when
I got here I had established so many
relationships from visiting over the
years
have you met Queen Latif for 30 years
ago and just over there's many people so
when I got here and I started going to
Supper Club I started going to Ladue I
started going to Garden of Eden then I
started popping up at Jamie Foxx I just
fell in love with the industry again
from a idea that I could abandon my job
to follow my dreams and over time it
happened and naturally when it was time
I just went Hollywood online full time
when did uh when did you like make the
decision to quit the job was it like
because you made a certain amount of
money they fired me oh they fired you so
you had really kind of like no choice
they didn't fire me because I did
anything wrong when we merged with the
the unions there became a lot of inner
Union fighting that I was it just was
beyond my pay grade so when they removed
our president I was very loyal to the
leadership and very I'm a loyal person
like when I arrived for you or ride with
you I'm 10 toes down period I don't care
what nobody says unless you do some real
crazy [__] right so they removed the
president and and they took all the
staff there's probably 300 some staff
they took us all into different hotels
around the state and we were faced with
a a decision you either
sign a letter and say that you to all
the members you've LED for all these
years that you were lying to them all
this time
or you just quit so we were faced with a
decision of lying to the people or
quitting and I just decided to quit and
I just quit so from there it was like
I'm all in now there's no other choice
there's no choice that's our
conglomerate group and I started putting
oh you want Chris Brown oh you want this
person okay 10 10 I started ten percent
in my my way into survival mode middle
man in a lot of deals absolutely I still
do it's a great hustle I still do it to
this day yeah that's dope yeah I mean
that's good to know so so for you like
when did you do you remember like a
month or like a a point in time where
you really realized like there was
really like some tread hitting the
ground with Hollywood unlocked like you
could you could turn this into something
that was like I mean I can't remember
the moment where I go this is actually
doing something like I remember when we
first started we started with a hundred
dollars what year was this it's 2015.
October 100 Instagram website and then
while I was building it I called Mona to
get on Love and Hip Hop but while I was
doing it we were so head down in the
work that we weren't paying attention to
the growth we just we weren't counting
numbers counting followers counting
comments we were just so into the work
and perfecting the storytelling and what
was going to differentiate us from our
competitors and how are we working with
those competitors to be collaborators
and we just head down and then I
remember we went for like zero followers
to like I remember I remember the day we
went to six we had 60 000 because that
was the day where we were like damn we
got 60 000 followers that's a lot that's
a lot yeah and then and then I remember
one day you had a hundred and it was 300
then it was 500 then it was a million
and so I remember all those moments of
where we were hitting those milestones
and we just kept trying to perfect the
the um consumer experience because
ultimately we at first were just a place
we're talking about what was hard what
was going on but then people started
picking us up and we were going all
across the world in different news
trades and then we started seeing
politicians reach out so we're like oh
damn then I remember an article came out
that we swayed an election so I'm like
okay we have real influence which
election was it this was back home in
Stockton okay I literally just said my
opinion on something and it got picked
up by L.A times and then different
people ran and then the vote literally
it swayed and the person came out and
said that it disgruntled work a
disgruntled former resident who used his
platform for him to lose and it wasn't
true it was just that you weren't a good
mayor and you needed to go so once I
started seeing our influence
then I was like yeah we're really honing
in on making sure that we were hitting
all uh demographics so pop culture all
things culture politics how do we hit
all these three things from a world
perspective like what do people want to
hear that the whole world can talk about
what can they talk about in Nigeria that
they'll talk about in London that
they'll talk about in La that they're
going to talk about in Arkansas how do
we create that content and then it
became a very strategic thing where then
we started looking at the needle like
okay this got 12 million views or this
guy okay now this show got x amount of
that's how we really looked at the
growth and now we're just we're just
growing more yeah uh you're also like
what I appreciate about you is that
you're very like
you'll hop on the feed of the and like
hey if you're serious about your
business
period hit us up because so many people
think that success comes by luck yeah
maybe if you hit the winning ticket in
the lottery right this [__] is a [__]
grind and I tell everybody online that
keeps posting these [__] tick tocks
and these boring ass pieces of content
you're lazy and nobody likes lazy
content everybody can tell it's lazy
some people may get that quick you know
overnight success the boonk gang's the
one hit wonders or whatever and that's
fine if that's what you want but if you
want sustainable success you have to
invest in your brand I paid for
advertising I advertise Hollywood
unlocked
um and I marketed the [__] out of my
[__] and if you have like an up and
coming business or like a product why
wouldn't you advertise your [__]
especially on a platform that creates
small business programs for people who
are new you know we have the fashion
novas of the world the McDonald's and
Pepsi but then there's you know somebody
may start a hair care company or a
t-shirt line or something you know we we
make sure we carve out space for those
people to be able to you know advertise
their brands too that's dope man yeah
for you when did you kind of like want
to expand because you know Instagram's
one business model yeah being a blog is
a business model but you've kind of
expanded the brand into so many
different like branches of like
uh just expanding the portfolio you know
obviously now we have the Jason Lee show
which which uh congrats on the first
episode of cardi B
um but when did you kind of realize like
yo there's just wait there's just so
much more here than just being a blog or
being the gossip site uh when my
Instagram went down because that was
like where most of our Revenue was
coming from and when that [__] went was
that 2019 it was 20
[__] I don't even it was probably
2017-28 it may have been it's a blur
announcement it was too it was I
remember when that happened because I
and then I would try to there was like a
different page you guys had right that
we had we had a [__] what do you call
those a backup page yeah the backup page
going yeah and then that became
complicated because then Instagram was
like if you lost Hollywood unlocked you
can't have a backup to that because you
lost because you lost it for a reason
company you know whatever it was crazy I
think once I lost that it scared me
because I think the thing that for me
that I never followed my dreams early on
was the fear of not being able to pay my
bills that's everybody's dream that's
that's everybody's fear which is why a
lot of people are afraid to start their
own Brands and they're afraid to quit
their full-time job the union was paying
me 5 000 every week every other week so
every other week I was I was Hood Rich
at on Thursday on Friday I was hoodrich
Thursday I was broke right but every
other Friday I was I had money so to
leave that I was forced to leave it but
then hustling to then leave all that to
really focus everything into put all my
eggs in one basket was scary and so when
I lost the Instagram my whole Focus was
okay [__] that when I come back we're
gonna diversify this brand we're going
to have at least 10 to 15 streams of
Revenue and if 10 to 15 streams of
Revenue or bringing in five thousand
each you can kind of do the math if we
do that on a monthly basis of course now
of course we're you know making
close to seven figures every month but
so now it's it's a more sustainable
model because now that the brand has
become validated and it's created its
own lane now it's just about how do we
plug and play into other areas yeah yeah
I think like uh the one thing that um
most people you were saying earlier the
fear of paying your bills it's like it
it it kind of like paralyzes people's
progress absolutely like so many people
I know like in my personal life have so
much potential and I always I'm like
like yo you should do this like I got a
homie who's like in the best shape every
works out every day and I've been trying
to convince him to be like a personal
trainer and start a gym for like it
feels like my entire adulthood and now
he just has a normal job and he's
miserable and I'm like dude you gotta
roll the dice sometimes you have to feel
like your dreams are worth fighting
through the fear you know my whole model
when I wrote my book God must have
forgotten about me I wrote about
um fear over faith a faith over fear you
know when I used to get on a plane early
on I'd be like oh my God this plan is
going to crash this plane is going to
all the turbines going to die but then
on one hand I'm over here listening
gospel music telling people that you
have to have faith in God you have to
have faith in this so I had to really go
back into what I believe what is my
faith what is the foundation of the
Jason Lee person and what is the founder
what is the foundational belief that the
Jason Lee experience should exude Faith
over fear so my faith is I had to find
the faith that I believed in myself
enough to get through the fear and most
people when I talked to him like I was
talking about therapists today I'm in
therapy I was saying to him I'm gonna do
so I'm gonna do this new show that I'm
selling to this network and I want to
bring you in to do this therapeutic
session but I was telling my creative
idea for I said why don't you do a show
where you sit down and work with people
who've been canceled and work through
why they've been canceled in a way that
makes them you know uncancelable that
sounds like a million dollar idea we're
talking about he was like yeah I would
do that because he rep he works with
other celebrity and public figures I'm
like yo I started telling my ideas and
he was like yo you're you're just you're
able to come up with ideas that is
unlike anybody else I said that's not
true I'm I'm able to focus because that
is something that I believe in and
anybody that believes in something if
they can just push past the fear like I
Feel Like Anything is Possible yeah I
saw you do like a breakdown of like all
the new [__] that's rolling out and it's
not just the Jason Lee show no it's like
you're doing a live stream this Jason
Lee experience you're doing like Monday
through Friday there's like gonna be
something right so there's the Jason Lee
show on Revolt
um and you're first person on this whole
run for people to ask me this question
because I think people are and I love
that people are focused on the show but
I what people when you made that
announcement I was like oh [__] yeah
that's that's a lot so the Jason Lee
show on Revolt we filmed we filmed five
episodes last last week before I went on
the Press tour but that's gonna air once
a week on Revolt 10 pm Eastern on remote
TV cable then the audio for that rolls
out the day before and so what was
holding up the deal was trying to figure
out where's this audio gonna live
because I was also in a negotiations for
a podcast deal
so the audio now rolls out on the Json
podcast on Mondays at Arizona Revolt
cable on Tuesdays and then Revolt
YouTube on Wednesdays and the experience
is different because you get a 44 minute
cut down on Revolt but then you get like
cardi B we gave a 44 minute cut down on
remote TV but then we did an hour and 27
minutes on remote YouTube so it's all
the stuff that you don't see on the TV
show you see on the YouTube and then
um I felt like okay what is it that I
don't want to be the talk show host or
the host that just talks to the audience
I want to hear from them what the [__]
they think about what we're talking
about so we created Jason Lee after dark
where that Wednesday when the YouTube
hits and everybody's seen heard it on
audio watch it on cable watched on
YouTube they can then come into a live
experience I can watch what happens
lifestyle right environment at night and
we can be drinking and talking and fans
can come in on these questions video or
call in
talk their [__] and then the Jason Lee
podcast will air on Fridays and then and
so the the Jason Lee after dark will be
on Hollywood unlocked.com we have a paid
um a paid place or membership placement
right help hey we got to stop the
interview to tell you about our folks at
my bookie that's right baby Super Bowl
is coming well you know in a month or so
we got the playoffs right now you could
get those future bets in on who you
think out of this uh barrage of teams
that made it to the playoffs is going to
win the Super Bowl you could bet player
props we can go NBA action on them so
much ways to make money with all the
sports going on and you could do it all
at my bookie right now if you go to my
bookie and you sign up for a new account
use the promo code bootleg and they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars you know what's dope
about my bookie not only can you bet on
your favorite sports
but you could also get a little
Blackjack going little slot machines in
that thing yummy a little loud little
roulette yeah me so much ways to get
paid on my bookie the most important
thing is though if you sign up
and you use the promo code bootleg at my
bookie go to my bookie my bookie my
bookie my bookie use the promo code
bootleg and they're gonna match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
right [__] now
listen I'm a degenerate but I'm pretty
good at this
I've been using my bookie for like 10
years all right very trusted they're the
best trust me they are the [__] best
wherever you're at if you're watching
this you can sign up for my bookie
account one more time that's my book you
use the promo code bootleg and they will
double your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars free [__] money
let's get to it all right boys back to
the interview let me understand because
I see a lot of big podcasts are going
the direction of doing deals with revolt
and having their content Live on
revolt's YouTube channel I I'm sure that
the monetary uh compensation is the main
motivation for that
for you though
you feel like a really strategic guy
yeah why not have
the Jason Lee show live on your own
channel that you own and you control
great I mean I know it's money but just
from like a person on this side of the
camera like I'm just curious you know
because I see a lot of people do it yeah
okay that's a great question one um
shout out to the tavio Samuels the um
CEO of brilliant they're killing it
brilliant black man who believes in
culture who believes in Black creators
who believes in creators a culture
period and I've been really big on
ownership of your content being able to
create strategic Partnerships to elevate
your brand
um finding people who believe in you as
much as you believe in yourself and
detavio did that you know I talked about
um Faith over fear and being able to
have like the you know there was a fear
to like run up on Diddy for a deal or to
hit ditty for a deal and then I've got
over that and I got his number and I
caught him directly and he put me into
tavio and Dion I just understand we've
been able to really craft a relationship
with Dion on The Daily on side and with
them on a Revolt what I love about them
and why I chose them over all the other
networks we're talking about is because
when we got into the weeds of the deal
ownership was important to me so I
um I share in the ownership of the
content I create with them but I own the
show name and I own a share in the
profit of the show equally so we're
Partners I don't work for them they
don't work for me but our teams have
integrated and aligned in a way where I
went with a five-person publicist team
and there's six publicist team and now
there's 11 publicists working on the
show that only amplifies the Jason Lee
brand that only amplifies the visibility
and I love the fact that they pay they
also do paid media as much as we do earn
media so the way we just work this whole
rollout with cardi over four billion
media Impressions over
um
7 million
um social media Impressions uh trended
number two on no I saw I saw you post
like the email screenshot of like the
stats it was crazy just and that's the
first episode right we plan to keep
going so yeah I think the fact that they
believe in the ownership and of the
content was great I don't know why
everybody else did the money is good
well I won't say it's not but you know
what I've been offered deals where
people come to me and said what if we
offer you 15 million dollars to come
over here but we own all your content
outright you own are you [__] done
yeah [__] that no God because I can get
the 15 because because you're obviously
financially well off compared to like a
lot of people like I'm not in your
business but I'm you're not doing too
bad
um but you could easily
I mean you did it with Hollywood the
Hollywood unlocked show right yes but
you could easily have pulled off this
entire thing without revolt's help I
could have but free but but I do think
that this is also a lesson that like
some people get so hung up and being
like nah I got this I'm over here on my
own that it's like
you said strategic Partnerships that can
benefit what you're doing I think some
people especially in like hip-hop
culture are so like hung up on being
independent now and not necessarily like
sometimes it's very beneficial to
partner yeah because the bag is bigger
in the long run yeah but you got to pay
attention like pay attention to all the
grades that are out there because I'm
paying attention right we just got our
evaluation 50 million evaluation
congratulations that's all you guys just
locked down some funding for like 1.8
million dollars well it's a little bit
more than 1.7 but because of the way
it's structured we could only announce
the 1.7 now but there's more to come but
you know we have some really good
strategic Partners a lot of people offer
me money oh this that whatever I still
owe 90 of the company I still have
control of the company and I still I
make the 10 is uh investors correct okay
there's a group of people that are
strategic so you know again these are
people who you know have access to
billions of dollars have access to huge
infrastructure I just met with somebody
yesterday who was like don't close that
round until I can get in there and this
person I mean you're gonna open the
whole world up in terms of Brands so
when I look at how I built it you know
Jay-Z said you know somebody who you
know people are afraid to to sell equity
in their business I mean if do you want
to get to that billion dollar status
it's not about what you giveaway it's
about how you how you sell it off or how
do you allow people to get in
strategically so if I have 50 of a
company that's worth a billion dollars I
walk away 500 million or would you
rather have 100 of the companies worth a
million dollars right right so that
really you just have to decide what you
want to do and that for me was always
like I look at the Jay-Z's I look at
like the pub daddy is the best marketer
in the business if you followed his
career from Uptown and I followed it and
so to be able to be on a network that's
black owned that he's actually
greenlit and that detavio is leading I
mean also even like even Diddy Look to
Him like Diddy bad boy had Partners in
the main you know whoever their major
distributor I mean it's Ciroc there's a
liquor partner there did he's the face
of it but it's like he's an extremely
smart man and I'll be very clear
everybody's I don't have a relationship
with him like that right I mean I got
his number he's on text but I we're not
on the phone every day like I am with
other people I don't have that
relationship with him
um and I don't know where the
relationship will go and I don't know
what the future holds but for right now
I really just really love what we're
doing over there and you know we have um
we have ideas for where we want to take
the show of course this is like we're
dating now like we're we're trying to
see episode one is a success that's for
sure episode one was colossal but you
know that comes with a lot of pressure
what's this episode two gonna do you
know episode three but I don't have any
I'm not worried about it because I know
that I'm more locked into this and I've
been in anything I've ever done for you
you have some strong alliances with
artists that you are your actual friends
cardi being one of them obviously
there's probably not anybody else who
could get the interview that you just
got
um how careful are you about covering
people who are your friends
I'm not careful I will say that my team
is I have to shout out the Hollywood
unlocked team especially the social
people and they're going to love that
you highlighted them because nobody ever
gives them credit they are
when [__] goes down and if say if it's
involving somebody they know I'm close
with they'll say heads up this is out
we're gonna run it here's our idea
they'll tell me it because like here's
the angle we're going to run it yeah
they're going to run what it is but
they'll tell us like this is what we're
going to say this is what we're gonna do
they give me an opportunity to call the
person and say hey this is about to run
do you want to tell me what's going on
or give me some input some most people
will give it to me others will not and
then we'll run it but if I hear from
them something that makes me go ah we
ain't running that you know like this
this is [__] and I've done that many
times where I've killed stuff that my
team wants to run because based on all
the information I have it doesn't make
sense uh but yeah I mean I don't
you know I was telling a cardi said on
the show how I told her I didn't like
hot [__] you know
um we were in a heated argument about
something completely unrelated because
we don't really talk about music or
right the news we just talk about live
[__] like that's I [__] love this
girl right so we're talking but we're in
a heated argument she she's cussing me
out I'm cussing her out and uh I said oh
and I think hot [__] is whack you know
and she was quiet and I really felt like
I heard her feelings but she's a thug so
she you know she came back at me
whatever but she appreciates me enough
to give me the space to be honest with
her and I to her and she criticizes me
so I don't know I don't have that
relationship with everybody though but
one person I will say that most people
don't know I know or have access to that
I don't I won't lie and say that we're
friends but we are very friendly on text
um and on the phone we need to be is the
weekend and he always
comes at the he only reaches out when
he's giving me my flowers which is which
is weird because we write about when his
voice fell out at the show and he just
walked off or when this or that or the
good things you know when he's become
hits all these different goals whatever
but we're not like super chatty on the
phone but it's something weird about
this guy where he always Tunes in to
give me my flowers when I'm making moves
and you know it's people like that that
like sometimes I just don't call because
I feel like they're they're gonna feel
some type of way about me or the work
that I do so I'm like I just kind of
stay away but um to the people that I do
have real personal deep relationships
with um I'm never going to compromise
what I do and those people that are my
friends know what I do and they
appreciate what I do so they can at
least uh understand like you have a job
to do they'll call me and be like that
was [__] up I'm like okay well what
you want to give me to you know what you
want to give me like what are we doing
you know how how many have you like has
there been a certain amount of times
you've taken stuff down because someone
asked you like Hey look
if it only I can only say that I took
the one thing that comes to mind and I
and I won't say it because it was a very
very tricky tricky thing I did take one
thing down once that I knew I put it up
on purpose to get the attention and once
the attention was got
I was able to say okay I'll take that
down but I only did that one time and I
and I'm and I'm growing learning how to
not use the platform like that to
intentionally get people's attention
because for a while when the doors
wouldn't open for me I was like you had
to shake the cage a little I have a
relationship with every artist in the
world every artist in the world I do
through Hollywood unlocked some just
don't participate if you participate
there's one experience if you don't then
you leave us to assume or gather the
facts that we get and then once it hits
the internet it is it is what it is yeah
so people are learning like I'm not
really trying to be the bad guy but make
no mistake about it I don't give a [__]
and I'm from Stockton California where
I'm where I was born and raised you know
um what's gonna happen y'all gonna kill
me because I said something okay well if
that's the way I'm going out I'll be
legendary I'm not worried about that I
was gonna say like I feel like you made
a transition everybody has growth but
from being like the Jason Lee who wasn't
as big as Hollywood unlocked and now
your your brand is kind of
parallel to your company
um do you feel like there was like
because you've had some public spats
with artists like you said early on you
would shake the the cage up I mean the
Nikki thing alone is you know um but do
you feel like there was like a an
incident or a moment in which you kind
of decided to move a little differently
in terms of like
stirring up unnecessary [__] see the
thing I really don't feel like I ever
started unnecessary [__] I feel like
everything I've started started or
startup was necessary I'm not gonna let
you bully me I don't care who you are
and I've had moments with everybody I
mean with everybody you could think of I
mean I've had moments with people that
people haven't even seen
um I don't think I've ever done anything
unnecessarily I just have I I just now
choose more strategically how I respond
you know sometimes
I'll deal stuff with behind the scenes
or whatever
um I'm trying to really live in my
purpose now I'm 45 years old
I'm still very hungry but I'm also very
blessed and have a lot of opportunities
in front of me um and so I think back
about a queen a conversation Queen
Latifah and I had where she said
really focus on building your audience
and then take them on a journey with you
but don't ever abandon them so the
people who love the tea that's what the
Jason Lee podcast is going to be about
big opinions very Unapologetic every
Friday you're gonna kind of like wrap up
the week oh my God very unfiltered yes
but you know less the whole dick [__]
[__] this that I mean just you know
um but but very very blunted um and then
um a very Unapologetic and then I think
the Jason Lee show I want to interview
Michelle Obama I want to talk to Barack
Obama these are people that are
important to me I don't want to scare
people to the extent that they don't
want to talk to me but I also want to be
able to keep around ask the questions
people want to know like I have to ask
cardi about the song that quavo did that
involves sweetie we'll have to ask her
about the lawsuit with Tasha K or nobody
else can ask these questions by the way
well they can't they can get the
interview yeah I don't know I don't know
no no this is what's going to happen
Cardi's gonna go to whatever she does
her run there's going to be a long list
from Dwight from Atlantic and it's going
to be like you can't talk about this you
can't talk about this you can't talk
about you're not getting that list I got
the list did you throw it away she threw
it away wow I got the list long [__]
list that's a lot cardi said nah we
doing it I mean
you're good you're good you're good let
me say this people don't understand the
[__] hard [__] that people that do
this go through what I've said at
Hollywood unlocked I'm not letting the
publicist tell me what I can and can't
ask I'm not Landing manager if you want
my audience if you want my consumer base
if you want to talk to me if you want me
to to make your [__] look good for my
world you can say you don't need it
you're not going to attempt because they
would never do it to Oprah never they
would never tell Oprah you can't talk
about this Oprah gonna sit down and say
Megan or Ellen or any of these [__]
Megan how you thought your black ass was
gonna go over there with them white
folks in London put a crown on and they
weren't gonna look at you as a black
girl girl bye you're never gonna be able
to tell Oprah what you can and can't ask
and so when I look at the culture now
and how how talk is just very much like
let's talk about your album I don't want
to just talk about your [__] album I
want to talk cardi wasn't on a radio run
cardi didn't have anything to promote
you're right she's pulled up and when
this list came
I'm not gonna say what I said but I I
didn't cardi called me as soon as I got
the list because I was in the chat
because she knew what I was going to say
and she just it was funny we had a
moment but then she pulled up and she
said ask whatever you want because she
knew that she could trust I was going to
be you're not going to try to set her up
with some gotcha [__] I don't do that
and and the great platforms don't do
that yeah yeah I don't do that but I do
feel like a lot of the platforms that do
do it is because they got to get
something because you ain't you [__]
tell them they can't talk about Jesus
they can't talk about oxygen they can't
talk about water they can't talk about
this table they can't even talk how
about how about you just don't ask me
any questions so you just want me to
talk about your album that's it I'm
never that person and I hate radio runs
when publicist would say
and this is just for example because I
love this person but Gucci Mane has an
album okay look if I'm number five on
that I ain't gonna know what the [__] to
ask him because I'm not you know that's
where you're gonna that's where you know
he's gonna walk into an interview and
I'm playing Jeezy yeah
to create a conversation or move but I
don't want that no more I want to be
able to authentically interview aguchi
and Akisha and be like yo you guys are
the epitome of black love in hip-hop
where we watch you like I mean she's
told me a story about how was that
interview coming soon I hope so Gucci I
want you and Keisha loves me and I love
her but you know her story of how she
like held him down while he was in
prison and started his Fitness thing
with him and how they got fit together
that's great yeah yeah uh for you like
that list though see y'all don't know
yeah those of you watching who want to
get in this world just know grind your
[__] ass off and be Unapologetic
because that was the one thing that
really pushed me to not give a [__]
because I would call different people
that I knew I helped out when I was the
plug like I knew you when you couldn't
get in a club I knew you when you wanted
to go over there and [__] on old boy and
I put you with him and now all of a
sudden you're this and that so now I
don't get no love that's why I started
saying like I see the games y'all gonna
play but how about this how about I just
because I'm I'm too in the business to
know what's going on to just sit silent
and be a co-conspirator in your [__]
so why not just put it out there and
force you because if I say something
and Vanity Fair picks it up you may not
like Urban press or black media and [__]
on us and think we're not important but
now you got to answer the Vanity Fair is
going to ask you the question
based on what I said and they're going
to cite me anyway so I still got the
credit so I figured out the way of like
really my [__] the business where
like you don't have to participate in
the relationship but I can still get
your attention yeah I think that one of
the like when I when I first watched
that Kanye interview did it was almost
two years ago now maybe a year and a
half out of here that was like where I
was like oh this guy's this guy's got it
like this this because you got a great
yay interview it was luck and shout out
to what whack help make that hack 100s
that's whack 100 he's the secret sauce
behind that relationship yeah I love
whack's a great guy man he doesn't get
the credit he deserves I I always I've
been friends with whack for over 10
years and I always say he's one of the
smartest dudes in the game I know
sometimes wackets on clubhouse and whack
is going to whack whack is very but he's
brilliant yeah he's brilliant yeah
people don't give him the credit and and
then the other thing I love and he told
the story recently and and I want to say
that like when when ice opened my studio
Hollywood unlocked Studios the idea at
first was very focused on a space for
creators to create a peer space type
situation yeah like that and then uh the
day it opened I was sitting in my
kitchen with um blue who was my former
co-host on the podcast I was like in
damage I was like how we gonna
I think damage was I know blue was there
because I was like how we gonna Market
how am I going to Market this I don't
know how to really do it like I don't
have never I just built the Space now
how do we Market it phone rings it's
whack literally yo yo yo nephew is yo
your studio open I'm like yeah he's like
um yeah I got somebody that want to rent
it it's okay let me talk to him so he
puts Kanye on the phone wow hello he's
like yo this is yay you know uh nice to
meet you you know I got and I'm like
sitting there put him on speakerphone
and we're like gagging like what the
[__] you know and he's like I want to
use my cousin pocket when can you come
to dinner where can you pull up I said
when you want me an hour I said okay I
went to Craig's
whack this is the thing that again
doesn't really happen because people who
plug people in want to be the gatekeeper
of that relationship and eat off of that
too forever
whack came in he sat me down next to
Kanye and he sat all the way across the
room completely let me and yay sit there
and Vibe for about four hours and really
talk and listen to music and he let me
hear all the you know different stuff he
had coming out for Donna too and then we
started vibing and I started just
telling him who I was when I was about
we clicked and then um the next day we
he called and said what you doing now so
I got Floyd Mayweather and Evan Ross at
my studio we chilling and they look at
the space he was like you want to have a
dinner tonight I got Madonna ask for if
he want to come and then we had this
epic ass dinner and then he got in a
fight with the I think I saw the
pictures from that night it was like you
and Madonna was there was Antonio Brown
there yeah yeah and then um
he got in a fight with the paparazzi
that night caught me the next day and
said well wax said like you know you can
help me with this that you have a
platform that I apologize I wasn't aware
and yeah talking about Hollywood a lot
he's okay let me know if I can come by I
said okay who'll come by you know we'll
talk about it whenever so I sent to the
address and I went into a meeting and
I'm in a meeting with this woman and her
artist and we're sitting there chilling
and then the ding dong at the doorbell
my Johnny my video director went open
the door and it was Kanye it's [__]
crazy he was like let's do it now the
interview now no prep no yeah we did it
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah blue chill gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry
senior year high school then go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg and get one month supply
for free that's right free all you got
to do is pay five dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue shoe
right to your [__] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[__] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [__] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[__] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [__]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not gonna perform it's
not it's not going to perform how you'd
like it to but you know how it will
perform if you're on that [__]
Bluetooth
you're going to put in a [__] Luka
donkic 61 Point [__] performance on
that [__] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview it's crazy too because like
then obviously you're kind of put in
charge of his what what was your title I
was head of media right for a very short
stint seven months seven months great I
left on my own amazing uh thing to throw
on the resume uh yeah I didn't think it
would be us I mean
I I want to kind of because you're you
could probably be like the best PR guy
in the game if you wanted to be yeah
a situation like Yay if you're his PR
person how do you how do you bring him
back how do you uncancel the situation
let's say he's level-headed he got
through whatever this weird like Hitler
White lives matter [__] was going like
what do you what's the advice you give
if he calls you tomorrow and says I got
a guy well I called him to give him the
advice I'm gonna tell you what I was
gonna give him right now and I haven't
told nobody this and I and I didn't give
it to him because of his response to me
when I called I'm a very genuine
authentic person
um I don't play games I'm not gonna like
sell nobody on nothing even if he wasn't
in his right mind if he at least wanted
to stop the bleeding to be able to focus
on finding his right mind to then get
back to the center what I would have
done
uh and let's be clear that interview I
did with him actually brought him closer
back to the center because the culture
forgave him we followed up with a media
brunch with all the top black
storytellers from all walks of media I
mean we did a Facebook I mean we did I
mean he was centered he chose to be on
centered again what I called him to tell
him that I didn't get to tell him
directly because he wanted me to put in
a text I don't text because he would
have probably screenshotted it and then
posted it and been like which is why I
chose not to text right what he could
have done because let's be very clear
what yay was saying
the topic that he was talking about was
a real topic the power construct of the
industry the power
um the lack of resources the
manipulation there's a lot of gems in
that drink Champs interview that get
overlooked because of the other [__] he
said the delivery was just completely
[__] wrong for sure you know Jewish
people and black people
Mexicans all different groups have had
very challenging experiences in their
communities the Holocaust slavery why do
we need a politic pain like everybody's
been through their [__] right and I've
been have relationships with Jewish
people who've brought me in and I felt a
sense of community where they were all
equally interested in my success in
pulling together resources unlike how
sometimes my community does so what he
was saying in terms of you know
different Power constructs and you know
opportunities and who owns what is true
how they did that I I would say we have
as a black community have to own some of
that because we choose to politic
positions oh I'm over here running this
so I'm not gonna let these [__] and
I'm gonna let these [__] in or I'm
gonna grandfather my homies in but not
put this [__] on who's on like there's
so many people who could have done more
for me when they saw me coming because
they saw the potential but they didn't
[__] with me I'm gay I'm this I'm loud
I'm whatever [__] them all now I got
more money than them so when I look at
with yay I said what he was doing I
agreed with the topic that he was
addressing but I didn't agree with the
delivery what I told him what I would
have told him from Dubai could have did
was during the time when he was burning
out with all lives matter Candice Owens
all that and doing all every random
[__] interview first thing I would
have said is you need to move very
strategic I would have
backed up from it all I would have hired
a production company I would have turned
this whole experience into a documentary
I would have pulled in Kyrie Irving I
would have examined America and race
relations in the world based on his
activity I would have made it look like
I did it on purpose on purpose I would
have here's this piece of art I would
have flipped it all up very artistically
on its head I would have interviewed
people from the Jewish I would have
pulled everybody in Candace Owens the
founder of black lives matter I would
have put everybody into this very
um inclusive work of art who could have
made us all take a step back to examine
how he was destroyed when he said what
he said when we have people who are
white climbing up the capitol trying to
kill the vice president overturn an
election who are still not in prison you
know there's a real conversation to be
had and and they still have their bank
accounts and they sell their bank
accounts you know since when does a bank
say come get your money out because the
news is saying well Wells Fargo probably
told him that because they stole Wendy
Williams money I don't know if his Wells
Fargo Chase but they I think it was
Chase they've all done [__] [__] you
know Wells Fargo taking all of Wendy
Williams money because they thought she
was incompetent there was no court
document or nothing that said that you
know when do you say pull out all your
money you do that because you want to be
in the news because you want people to
go and look at your products and
services they used him and he allowed
himself to be used what I'm really big
on is controlling your narrative how do
you
create a conversation that may make the
whole world blow up but when you shake
it out it's it it it it it it it shapes
into this work of art that actually
makes people go back and start having
critical thinking he wasn't able to
really do that because I think he was
too emotionally involved in it you know
and he had some really good people
around him that could have helped him
and then unfortunately he wanted me to
text him that
um but I I said I'm not going to text
you no problem because I I don't I told
him I said I don't want you to pay me
for this idea I don't want to be
involved with this idea I don't want any
credit for this idea I don't want any
public association with this idea that's
what I was going to tell him I just want
you to be able to stop the noise of what
you've created now with this whole
conversation around a topic that is a
real topic we could have elevated
through our relationship but that you
chose to go nuclear on because you had a
point to prove and now you're being sued
by everybody and you're going to lose
everything and you're going to feel like
you're right because ultimately if he
runs for president now and Trump runs
for president and he loses he can can
say the only reason Trump won is because
White lives matter he can say that but
by this point you've turned the whole
world off from listening to that yeah I
feel like he kind of like um
he kind of like unintentionally hoard
himself out to the alt-right content
space to where like and I don't think it
was his intent you know what I mean but
I think that like when you go on like
certain podcasts and you talk to certain
people it's like you're you're kind of
just like
giving them all the ammunition that they
need to kind of continue to push hate on
their side while you're kind of
oblivious to that because you think that
you're like I don't it's just very he's
my favorite artist ever so it's like
well I said he's he definitely is
gaslighting the culture and he's serving
up uh white supremacy you know and it's
unfortunate because I will say this as
much as I've been critical I'm also very
much a fan I think he's one of the most
brilliant artists in the world he's
definitely a culture disruptor culture
shifter culture leader icon all that
he's all of that but all of that you can
still be flawed I think the one flaw
that yay has and I say this with love
um is that he just he he the the the
Putin and the the Hitler references is
more about kind of being that
uncheckable dictator that controls the
world as he wants to see it and not be
questioned uh but that's just not the
reality where we live in you know I
think you got to like read the room and
I I think the Hitler [__] that he was
saying was like coming from a place of
like Jesus loves everybody Jesus
forgives everybody I love Hitler I love
Jews but I just felt like
yeah sometimes you got to read the room
man you know it's Jesus May forgive
everybody but that don't mean you ain't
going that I mean you ain't gonna go to
hell and burn to death you know what I'm
saying yeah it was just unfortunate to
see you like you said it's like we've
never this is a one-of-one situation
probably the most culturally important
person that hip-hop has probably ever
had he's moved fashion musically he's
that guy and it just kind of like four
months and it's just evaporated it's
kind of crazy crazy thing is I think he
could come back I think he could too you
know I think he'd come back but like he
has
you know I I will say it was a it was an
honor to be able to be there my whole
goal was not to be like known for being
his head of me and all that that's great
that people know that he put me in a
room with the president of Gap with the
presidents of Adidas with the leaders of
these organizations who
um at the time were spending no money in
marketing no money in our communities to
seed programs and so as head of media
I I found my way into conversations with
people to say if he makes you three
billion dollars can you not put five
percent towards programs in our
community and they were on board with
this they were like they were hungry for
ideas he just needed a green light he
never did so the frustrating part was
the idea of what we wanted to do was we
had a billion dollar commitment outside
of the U.S to raise to to get this money
to buy all these media conglomerates to
be able to put them under one house that
I would sit on and help to really shape
narrative for the culture
and on top of that be able to get these
Fortune 500 Brands to be able to spend
hundreds of millions of dollars pouring
back into our community that's the
privilege that I thought I had there and
then it became a circus and and when I
realized like I'm a very strategic
person once I saw like this is not what
it is I don't want to spend the time I
have on earth like playing around like I
want to leave an imprint a legacy do you
think he had a lot of yes people around
him and you're obviously not a yes man
so like being in that short amount of
time would you say that his inner circle
was pretty just kind of like no I won't
say that I'll say that he had a lot of
really good
people
who did the work that needed to be done
and when it was time to say no would say
no but it was typically through me which
made me the bad guy right and and when
they said no they said it in ways that
would get him to understand there's a
need to pause and then I would come in
with the no right why and I think
strategically we all worked well
together like everybody had their Lane I
wasn't management I was you know I but I
became a let's how do we put out this
fire yeah what's your advice on how we
do this and he never wanted to do it so
you know it wasn't that I didn't have
all the answers or that he didn't need
all the answers I just think that he
wanted to do things his way and now he
can look at his world and see that that
probably didn't work out in his favor
but I won't say it was because everybody
around him was bad he had really good
people I mean he had the best
um divorce attorney the only one I think
that could have beat Kim Kardashian at
least leveled it out for him he had the
best um other attorneys the Gap person I
mean everybody around him was they were
good people but you know he chose what
he chose and here we are yeah uh you
executive produced the show uh is it
Bobby light is that Bobby I love you per
the a show yeah it's crazy because now
like I feel like on if I go to like a
Hollywood unlock you guys post a lot of
clips from uh they buy a lot of
advertising what's the name of the
network who's network oh my god Zeus
network is lit they're killing it Jesus
they're killing it they lend me a shot
to let me know they they buy advertising
they do great and they pay on time so
that's so let me ask you that because
you guys will post like every show that
they have there's like a clip that goes
on holiday they pay for it so that is
paid advertising yeah we're paid media
we're not earned media well that's
double because I want people to realize
like Zeus network is killing it and
they're they're paying for everything
they're investing in their brand limio
doesn't he has a great he does a great
job of cultivating relationship he
nurtures a relationship with his talent
he makes them feel valuable he gives the
back end on top of what he pays so like
he paid me to Executive produce it he
paid me so there's front end pay there's
back in pay he paid me to host he pays
for advertising I mean he really invests
in his brand and I'm sure he's reaping
the benefits because I can imagine two
million one million two million you know
subscribers at 5.99 you're killing him
it's crazy when you see something like a
blueface and Christian rock situation
that like obviously is very uh probably
good for numbers for Hollywood unlocks
because every other day there's some
going up but it's obviously a very toxic
a toxic and it could end up being a
tragic situation I just feel like it's
like spiraling into a place that like
like I saw the no jumper thing that
happened yesterday and I was just like
[__] man like it's there's been domestic
violence there's been a lot of wild [__]
do you ever feel like
we contribute to that yeah
I know you're going with that um let me
say that they are my next guests on my
show okay um episode two episode two
very different but also very similar but
also very different they didn't kick
[__] break [__] was none of that
um because when I went into that
interview I wanted to try to humanize
the madness because I see what we post
and there are times where I will call
limio and say okay I think we're it's
going a little too far like I'm not
doing this ad or we need to do this
because but at the same time there's
also a part of the culture that wants
that like there is an audience that
follows us that likes that and that kind
of [__] has been missing from the
entertainment space for a while well
Love and Hip-Hop had to soften itself up
once the George Floyd stuff happened
because black lives matter was and also
like Jerry Springer's gone so I feel
like that's kind of like low-key like
and here's my excuse and this is what I
and people are gonna say that's no
excuse it is an excuse
this is a black owned Network and if
we're going to profit off our pain or
profit off our struggle or our community
issues I'm more comfortable doing it
with people than Viacom than Viacom
because bet is owned by a white woman
right Jewish woman
um and people don't know that and I'm
not going to politic my answers around
that but I just feel like it's different
like lemio took this Talent Bobby Joslin
um Nelly none who are on mainstream
networks who were not getting paid what
they were due who are not getting you
know the money that that they should
have gotten on the back end Jocelyn
helped build Love and Hip-Hop I mean
Love and Hip Hop well when they got
Atlanta is when it really blew up for
sure no no no no no for sure right for
sure and I know and there's no shade
Demona who gave us all an opportunity
but like Viacom did not pay us what we
were when I did Love and Hip Hop season
one I got a thousand per episode wow the
Thousand per episode so the episode I
threw a drink on Hazel E I got paid a
thousand dollars for it that killed me
in many ways because it it forced me
into a space that I did something I
regretted and I could not fix it because
they weren't even willing to help me fix
it there's a publicist over there I
think her name is I think it's Shelly I
can't think of her I can't think of her
name but
Kelly her name is Kelly this woman who
didn't look like me did nothing to help
me fix your image or my image or no
press no she did nothing to help she lit
and then tried to uh uh she tried to
Black Bomb me from going to the VMA she
tried to do all types of [__] because
she wanted to flex her power when really
this was a show where a bunch of black
people were coming treated like Bottom
Feeders and given scraps to go and beat
each other up from for for the for for
the fame I never wanted Love and Hip-Hop
for that I used it as a marketing tool
like this is a stepping stone to get in
front of the world launch my brand like
I don't know what the [__] these [__]
doing I don't care about any people like
that I don't want to be mixy anyway
literally if you saw me on set it was
how much more time okay we filming in
five four three do my thing and I was
out I never politicked with them I never
hung out I never want to be friends with
these people because it was never about
that for me and when I look at Zeus he's
taking Joslin these people are making
more money than they probably have ever
made in television and he's giving them
ownership over the shows EP credits so I
give him his his props for that that but
I do sometimes look at the content go
this doesn't necessarily align with what
Jason Lee is about
but it is in the ecosystem of what
Hollywood unlocked is and that's where
when you talk about I appreciate you
saying that where the Jason Lee brand
and the Hollywood unlocked brand are two
separate Brands although I own Hollywood
unlocked I'm putting me out more so you
see that my core brand is focused on
empowerment entertainment and um and
education so through empowerment through
my Foundation entertainment through my
platforming shows and education through
my courses hey we got to stop the
interview you real quick to tell you
about our family at hardean that's right
Hardin Las Vegas the craziest dispensary
in the world the number one dispensary
in the United States let alone in Las
Vegas all right maybe you're hitting
Vegas with your friends your girlfriends
whatever maybe it's a bachelor party
whatever's going on you're going to go
watch the Raiders suck [__] whatever it
is make sure you pull up to Hardy in Las
Vegas tell him I sent you they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
I've ever seen in my [__] life the
pre-rolls the cartridges the Edibles the
flower all top-notch all the best the
bud tenders are so friendly it smells
great it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniffed that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed all right so go follow them right
now Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot
him a follow get all the details you
need you can get you some of this fly
ass Harding merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview I'm always curious
man being uh gay in the hip-hop industry
yeah it's obviously a very homophobic uh
genre of music historically yeah cause
the rapper sucking dick ain't gonna tell
you they're not going to tell you that
these [__] out here sucking dick
[__] trans they're not gonna tell you
these [__] out here [__] and
you know what they never really [__]
with me because one I think I mean of
course I'm cute I'm well dressed I'm
rich and by the way you're 45 and you're
yeah 45. black don't crack God bless you
does crack when you're broke okay black
don't crack when you got good
Dermatology well you look great thank
you but the thing about it is I mean my
career has [__] off my dating
opportunity in the hip-hop Community
because these [__] Ain't Gonna slide
them ideas because they know like or
they don't know they assume that I'm
gonna put them on blast which if they
follow me I don't out people I don't
attack children and you know um there's
one more thing I can't think of but you
know there's just some certain things
that I don't do but
um I know that a lot of reasons why some
of these hip-hop artists don't call my
show is they have skeletons and they
think that if they sit in that chair I'm
going to throw them out I would never
out them you know but I also feel like
they've never outright disrespected me
for being gay because you know you throw
some [__] at me I'm a no pun intended
I'm gonna throw some [__] at you
um but I don't really feel like I don't
get disrespected but I do feel like
there's a sense of with some artist
sense of fear to you know come and sit
and talk with me because of what they
think I may say I was gonna say do you
feel like that the like like it feels
like
the homophobia is kind of chilling out a
bit when you got a guy like little nazex
who's obviously a [__] pop star but
you know I I guys like yourself are do
you feel like the the level of that [__]
is at least kind of like
started to kind of I will say that I
think that mainstream still uses artists
like little nazex or Saucy Santana to
break the barrier by showing a image of
what being black and gay looks like
that's not always what it looks like
right I'm proud of Saucy Santana in his
hustle because I've seen him behind the
scenes I went to the rehearsal with him
and Madonna Madonna invited super nice
guy super that but super professional
he's on his [__] like he really is
excited I had like one of my funniest
interviews with him ever like he was
great he's great and Lil Nas X for him
to be able to continue to live in his
truth and do what he's doing I mean I'm
fans of both but I also believe that
like the industry for years has made the
black male the black gay male experience
on TV and in mainstream be an accessory
to a reality star housewife or a [__]
wearing heels and makeup and that's not
all of us like some of us are just real
[__] who grew up in the hood and who
happen to be gay but like who I'm
[__] and who's in my bed should have
no Martin should have no influence over
our relationship because I'm not trying
to [__] half the people that think I'm
trying to [__] them right but I will say
that um I do think it's getting easier
now
um for people to see us because the
representation is there but
what really makes it easier is when you
see a jack Harlow perform with a little
nice X not when you see Lil Nas X
performing at the BET Awards in front of
the people and then they pan to the
hip-hop artists and everyone's acting
uncomfortable right when half of you are
[__] trans and Men Behind Your Baby
Mama's back
um so that kind of [__] makes me
uncomfortable because I'm like don't
[__] play around don't [__] play
around because what you don't want is
you don't want me to stop wanting to
protect your secrets when I could really
level the playing field and say okay
um so and so you remember my homeboy
such and such and then boom now they on
my show I would never do that but I'm
just saying like I do get frustrated
sometimes when I see certain artists
seemingly uncomfortable when you know we
know if we pulled the curtain back
there's a skirt under there right yeah I
think that like there's a few instances
over the last couple of years where I
was just like like me and boozy talked
like he was on my show and I was trying
to explain to him why he's pretty
homophobic and he just was not agreeing
with me the whole time I want him on my
show that'd be great I'm we're talking
if you that listen I'd pay I'd pay good
money to watch you and I'm working on it
that would be great working because I
think I think he you know
people meet me and they have a different
experience and it allows them to be
open-minded I don't know he has put he's
been 10 tones down for what he believes
in and I'm ten toes down for what I
believe in but I'm able to have a
conversation where I can help a person
see like you know if you think about it
if you are a woman and you're homophobic
then you're you're you don't believe in
feminist rights of women having equal
pay them in you don't believe in being
able to have the right to vote you don't
believe in any you know you don't
believe in having control over your
bodies if you believe in all those
things then how could you not believe
another Community should have the same
should have the same belief that they
should have those rights too because
it's not going to take away from what
you got right me [__] some dude ain't
gonna doesn't mean I want to [__] your
kid doesn't mean I want to [__] your
husband we're not pedophiles we're just
in our community so what is it that that
makes you uncomfortable about what we're
doing when it has no effect on what
you're doing now if you say oh well my
kids have to see your kids you also paid
for your kid to get head from a woman
who gave you head so who could say that
they would pay to get their dick sucked
and then let that same mouth go suck the
dick of their underage child you can
call that what you want people strange
little strange every Community has his
[__] yeah but you can't say that's a
little strange but then look at our
community and say that's [__] weird
it's all weird if if weird is weird it's
all weird or it's just your preference
in ours we prefer to do [__] that you
don't do you prefer to do [__] that we
don't do but we have to get to a place
where like gay [__] ain't going
nowhere and these these these these hood
[__] who grow up with whatever they
grew up with they they're not going
anywhere so how do we co-exist in a
world where we're not judging each other
and attacking each other but you're just
coexisting yeah I think uh I think we're
getting we'll probably to be to a place
in like 20 or 30 years we're like just
like everyone's [__] everybody it'll
be there when me and Boosie had an
interview dude
Boosie is on my short list I I I I
respect them enough to have the dog oh
he's a legend yeah and he's uncancelable
he's like one of the few guys who could
just do anything and it's like his Nick
he's [__] boozy like what do you want
from him like my cousin loves Boosie
Boosie's gonna boozy Boosie my cousin
Anthony from Stockton he said bro you
gotta give this is like when I wasn't
really on Boost because at first it was
a lot to digest well listen being from
the West Coast yeah I also I knew about
boozy I knew some of his [__] but then I
moved to Florida and I really saw like
oh he's there Tupac for real really like
I moved to Tampa Florida when he got out
of jail I was living there yeah you'd
have thought like the good loves Jesus
got resurrected out of the [__]
Clearwater Beach ocean like they love
yeah they love me like my cousin he he's
the he's the barometer of the boozy and
the NBA young boys and all that world
he's like yo you gotta get busy so I'm
working on it okay before you go I want
to play the uncancel game with you one
time okay okay
you're put in charge of Tory Lanez and
his PR
two scenarios before he landed what
Tori's a good friend of mine yeah so I
like Tori I know um he's a good guy I
mean listen he [__] up obviously so
yeah
he's been a good guy to me let's just
say that but
let's say the day after all this happens
he's in jail you're his PR guy
how do you handle this what do you tell
him to do
stay off the phone
but I'm saying like Okay I mean when you
realize all this is going to come out
it's getting ugly do you tell me just
come out and admit it dude no I mean I
think you know whatever a person goes
through legally is they're privately is
their business but I feel like once you
get on there once you make a song and
then you write horse or something
referencing a horse when you know Megan
the stallion you put out the album the
day that the uh what was the verdict of
the young lady who got killed uh by the
cops uh um
Brown Taylor Brianna Taylor yeah the
same that yeah it was okay when you pop
out when you have debate when you have
uh when you pull up on the baby set
right after Megan got off stage you're
rolling loud when you yeah when you do
all of that I mean like you're not I'll
quit you're not quit like you can't
really when you politic the media to try
to create a narrative that you're
innocent when you know that the Trials
come in and at some point the stakes are
so high your freedom in this country is
at stake your career is at stake
women your audiences women are sick like
you're going at some point you're making
all these decisions because people
believe the court of public opinion is
more important than anything so you're
trying to Gaslight people but what he
failed to realize is that ultimately
women who've been victimized by men for
years are going to switch whenever the
conversation changes and the
conversation changes and so yeah I would
have just advised them to
stay focused on his music stay focused
on rehabilitating that relationship stay
focused on all things positive you can
change The Narrative of positive content
but he wanted to be the bad boy of r b
and or whatever he doesn't right any
advice you would give for up-and-coming
Content creators
go to my go to this is a plug
mediamillionaires.com literally right
now our courses have been we sold some
courses during Black Friday and then we
shut it down to really um focus on the
community that we're building the media
millionaire University where I'm gonna
do bi-weekly coaching sessions and all
the stuff that we're building to give
these people access to people who are
creating change in the game
um I would say you have to find a way to
invest in yourself and get educated if
it's not my course go to college and
take the courses that are important to
you or you know go watch all the bunch
of podcasts
um but you have to be educated and know
what you want to do and be very
strategic know what your exit strategy
is oral should be working 10 years at
something that has no end I have an end
in 10 years I have a plan to be fully
gone if I want to be or politics
you know
I would say that the only reason I would
say no to politics is because I've done
so much [__] [__] that by 10 years from
now they're gonna be like that [__]
never but then again Donald Trump let's
begin Trump this guy this guy Trump was
he was Mr [__] [__] boy Rd I will say
you know I do if I wasn't doing what I'm
doing now I would be doing politics or
I'd be working in the union but um I
have Ambitions to be an investor I want
to invest and help build companies and
and and partner and Seed in companies so
yeah I don't know of politics but I
won't lie my Foundation is very much
organized built on an organizing model
where we do want to have influence in
local and National politics hey hey we
got to stop the interview to tell you
about our family at odd sucks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
[__] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [__] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [__] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [__] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [__]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[__] [__] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [__] ethica or
some [__] ass [__] Nike socks
[__] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview for you like
um being close with like the Democratic
side of of uh
the political Spectrum
um the last four years has been like
there well last six years uh has been
just I feel like we're like still like
in a South Park episode kind of it's
kind of [__] crazy
um but like the like the left has kind
of
rebounded a bit and now there's all
these Joe Biden documents that are
popping up in [__] a million
different places I feel like Donald
Trump radicalized like an entire part of
the country that was just asleep
and and while doing that also
radicalized everybody who's on the
extreme far left how the [__] do we like
move together as a nation in your
opinion and try to kind of like because
I feel like just the divisiveness of the
country it it I thought that like Biden
getting elected might help it but it
doesn't feel like it's
you know listen he's kind of just a
zombie up there just you know trying to
get through his [__] term I'll say
Joe Biden is he's he's doing a lot for
the black community that is overlooked
because all the other stuff in kind of
so is he because you've heard because
I've heard I've heard I've heard people
be a little like like after Charlemagne
say that he had made some promises that
he did not follow up with I mean the
George Floyd policing actor me and like
me and Charlemagne made agree to
disagree Charlemagne's far more
intelligent than I am in politics so I
kind of just let him do whatever and
whatever but I mean like they did
develop we talked about this on
Breakfast Club the other day like they
did
um establish the um the anti-lynching
bill which is the first time in history
which should have been done a long time
ago but he did that you know the person
running the um the defense right now is
a black man the person managing the
national budget is a black woman
um when you look at you know
um the the press secretary for the
president and the vice president they're
both black women one's a black queer
woman so he has done a lot in the terms
of putting us in positions to be able to
like see visibility and see us there but
then also like him exonerating all the
people who've been arrested for federal
marijuana charges I mean you know the
student loans I mean he's done a lot and
A lot's always Never Enough well I'm not
going to say he's perfect because you
know that would be a lot but you know
what's the alternative Trump oh no no no
no listen I voted for Joe Biden if he's
if it's if it's Joe Biden's corpse or
Donald Trump in 2020 whatever the [__]
2024 I'm right give me the skeleton but
I will say if I had to give advice to
people man [__] all that National [__]
that's something but pay attention to
your local politics we just got Karen
bass selected here in L.A Karen bass is
somebody who helped me get somebody out
of prison I interviewed her on my show I
felt she was the real deal I work with
politicians for years at the union I
called her on the side and said hey I've
been trying to get a friend of mine out
who's 24 years old he's locked up in a
prison recently in Kansas a couple years
ago okay he was 24 at the time I from my
hometown it was somebody that we all
knew and first time offender got
arrested for a pound of marijuana and it
got eight years I just felt like that
was so I caught I caught everybody from
Kim Kardashian to Van Jones to this
group this group and I was feeling
helpless but then I started feeling like
again with anything I do in my career if
I feel like I want it bad enough I'm not
gonna [__] play and he would call me
every other day and still being very
positive but you know what I felt like
what happened was wrong and wanted me to
help him
so I called Karen on the side said hey I
really feel passionate about this and
she started talking about challenges
with prison reform and that this was a
real thing and blah blah and then covet
happened so I was calling the governor
in that state Governor wouldn't return
my calls
Karen got her attorney as the
congresswoman wow on the phone with the
governor and her attorney and negotiated
his release and fully exonerated him and
now he just got his license wow so like
she's the real deal so when she was said
she was running for mayor I was like no
[__] way I'm not helping her and then
to see Kim Kardashian snooping different
people come out and support for the
other guy the other guy who had just
become former Republican who just became
a Democrat because he's running in La
yeah exactly but people don't pay enough
attention to the local politics where
that's what affects your [__] that's
what affects what's at home so yeah that
National [__] is important the local
[__] is the most important though it's
the most important so get involved and
once you get involved with local
politics you start to understand like
how to be involved local Statewide
nationally like how you understand
climate change you know conversations
happening in Paris for the whole world
affect us and when we when our President
says we don't believe in that Shin pulls
out and then you start seeing you know
you go to New York and there's no
[__] snow on the ground you're like
yo it's warm it's beautiful in New York
no [__] this is this is not good
because there's not snowing it's not
snowing in New York in the winter that
means that climate control is out of
control and what is this going to look
like for your kids and your kids kids
and I don't think people are connected
enough because they're too busy [__]
tick-tocking and wearing the right photo
on Instagram that they're disconnected
from the fact that the world's falling
apart actually it's kind of by Design
too of course yes
in China The Tick Tock experience for
kids is way different yeah out here
they're like yeah feed them all the
[__] yeah keep them distracted it's
crazy well listen man uh you got a lot
going on uh when's episode two come out
with Christian rock and blue free
Tuesday at night 10 p.m Eastern on
revolt and then the YouTube is Wednesday
yep Monday is the audio Monday is the
audio you can download the J sleep
Thursday is after dark Wednesday night
after dark Friday is the Jason Lee
podcast Thursdays we're giving them a
break Thursday nothing going on yeah I
mean you can really you can take a break
you can take a break yeah uh Hollywood
unlocked uh anything else you want to
plug your obviously got your charity nah
just you know I'm just living life I
appreciate you know people like you
doing your homework and being a good
interview I'm a fan man I think you're
dope and like I I you know you got into
it with a friend of mine uh Peter
rosenberg's my boy you know but but no
no but it's funny because when you got
in into it with him I had your side did
you really yeah because I did you talk
to him about it no but I I like dm'd him
about or something I I just I I thought
that like I actually forgot what
actually the argument was about but I
think in terms you were kind of speaking
from somebody who's like an owner who
owns your [__] well and I appreciate it
I'll say this okay Peter if you're
watching I love Pete man that's my guy I
never wanted to hate on Peter and he's a
good he's a great guy he probably is
with like pure intentions here's my deal
don't [__] start [__] with me like I
literally be minding my business unless
it's my business to mind the business
that we're speaking right I never hated
him I never you know he's whatever he's
Peter Roseburg he's built his name and
I'm building mine but I do take it
personal when people personally when
they personalize and attack me and think
that I'm not gonna attack back so I did
say to Noriega yo I'm coming on drink
Champs bro I'm gonna [__] come on
there and just talk my [__] but I even
tell Peter Rosenberg and I wasn't even
focused on Peter but once he asked for
about Peter on the show I made it by him
but I did see recently like he kind of I
think he emailed me or DM me or
something I think he tried to connect
with me and we haven't connected he's a
nice guy yeah but I did say [__] High 97
as a company [__] that whole brand [__]
everybody over there it's up we don't
support them they recently tried to
interview me I told him [__] them no and
you know what until they make good and
make you because I'm not sucking
nobody's dick you know punitended for a
[__] look because I have the look I
have the platform already I'm not gonna
do that I don't need to go do a [__]
radio run with you know these [__]
losers Ebro from from Sacramento before
he was he was from Sac but I knew era
before but you know he has selective
memory I don't know if his agent or wait
he just forgot me he doesn't remember
whatever but I had a lot of respect for
Ebro as like the local Molly Mall from
Stockton absolutely I grew up with Molly
and my brother were best friends
yeah but you know I don't hate Ebro
either I'm just not I don't I don't you
know I'm I'm not none of these I'm not
subservient to none of these guys Ebro
still comments on Hollywood I'm like we
haven't blocked him you know we haven't
I don't even blocked a lot of people
though huh what's The Blacklist over
there but more than a thousand nah nah
we really don't block people like
because what about you me oh my [__]
yeah my [__] yeah yeah I got at least I
got at least 2 000 people blocked I
don't have that many or the early Love
and Hip-Hop days yeah like when people
like leave some like when I would like
say some political [__] and some Mega
[__] be in my comments of block
but you can filter your comments now and
you can restrict people so they don't
know you blocked them I restrict people
I don't block them when you restrict
them they can't leave comments no more
yeah but but I will say Floyd told me a
long time ago why would you give
somebody the privilege of knowing they
got your attention because if you
because if you block them they're like
oh they I got to him right he's like he
was like I don't know he was like I
don't I don't even you know but of
course he's a billionaire so if you and
Floyd are close you have a Money Team
bracelet now I know plenty of strippers
walking around Los Angeles right now
that have Rolexes per The Money Team I
mean I have Rolexes I have Rolex I have
uh Hublot but he that's his token of
appreciation to his team in general the
men and the women the women get us a a
certain type of watching the men get a
certain type of watch and uh for a long
time I wouldn't accept any gifts from
him because I really want him to know
the relationship was genuine it was
really I just I was just
um I was really inspired to see somebody
come from a Stockton Grand Rapids and
[__] hustle and become a billionaire
off of his talent right and I wanted and
I had a front row seat to like learn
from this guy I talked to him today
matter of fact on the way over here yeah
I talked to him so I mean yeah I mean
he's been a great supporter so once I on
one of my birthdays several years ago he
gave me the Hublot when he was fighting
I don't know if it was Pacquiao where he
was fighting he gave me a Hublot he gave
us all of us in the room of Hublot and
then when I got my last podcast deal
with Foxhole he gave me a Rolex but now
I built I bought on my own watches you
know I bought my own jewelry hey you're
rich rich man I'm not rich rich but I'm
50 million dollar evaluation rich
Hollywood unlocked
congratulations on that and thank you
for coming man lots of hard work and
dedication hard work and dedication yes
there it is hey Jason Lee my guy thanks
for any time yes sir